um i also like to thank the organizers
for giving me this opportunity to talk
about how to gauge time versus symmetry
and also thank everyone for coming
because i know this is uh this has been
a long day and i'll try to keep it short
all right so this is uh this is worked
down by me and ashman um so we put this
archive number here just in case you're
interested this is a good thing about
making slides that i can have the
acronym number available
um so
anyway okay
so um
um so gauging time resource imagery is
something
weird to talk about maybe because
because people talk about gauging about
gauge theory gauge field whatsoever and
also people talk about timing what's so
symmetric but
um
to my knowledge these two parts are not
put together very often so today i'll be
talking about how tensor network might
be a platform to make sense of this
weird concept
okay
so i'll be uh so my talk will have three
parts i'll first talk about what is
gauging time so what do i mean by that
and why do i want to do that because
it's a it's something um not usually
done in physics it's something that you
you can
you could i i cannot imagine go to a lab
engage time also and uh thirdly um how
do i
gauge time versus symmetry using tensor
network representation of many body
quantum states
and actually um
in the end of the talk you might see
that this is related to some
common practice that has been used a lot
in the study of matrix product states
and sometimes higher dimensional
generalizations of this and
i was surprised by that
okay so first let me talk about what is
what do i mean by gauging time versus
symmetry
so people talk about gauging one
so usually the context is that the
system has certain symmetry
and
if the system has certain symmetry you
can talk about coupling the system to a
gauge field and actually the it's um the
simplest example everybody is very
familiar with that is
for example we take a system with charge
conservation symmetry and the simplest
one is just a conductor
electric wire where the electrons in the
in the wire number the number is
conserved
and we can couple this wire to an
electric magnetic field and electric
magnetic field is the corresponding
gauge field
for the symmetry of charge conservation
so what we can do is that sorry we can
couple the wire to a battery and add a
voltage across it and make a current or
we can make a
loop ring a ring loop
out of this wire
and put some magnetic fields through the
through the loop so this is coupling
on a conducting wire
to electric and magnetic field
so this is very simple and we do it
every day
and
so
the gauging i'm going to talk about
today is more in this sense that is we
make some kind of loop and we will put
some flux through the through the loop
okay the second word in the title is
time inverse so what is time move so
time also is reversing time
but you actually so mathematically means
that uh you take t and put it to minus t
but actually in physics in real world we
never reverse time so it's more of a
theoretical formulation but
there are many quantities that are
affected by this time reversal operation
for example there are certain quantities
that are preserved like the position of
a particle or the mass or the charge or
the electric field generated by a
certain charge configuration but there
are also other physical quantities that
are reversed by this operation of
reversing time was so for example
momentum
the particle going that way will be
going backward and also current
and spin spin is
formed by a current loop so if a current
is reversed the spin is also reversed
and related to that the magnetic field
generated by uh the current auto spin
so
so we have many um
simple examples of condensed matter
systems where time reversal is either
breaking or it's a time also invariant
for example we can have a ferromagnet
which has a net
magnetization and because the
magnetization is reserved is reversed by
this time reversal operation we say that
this ferromagnet will break timeless or
symmetry
and we can also have time-wise invariant
system and the paramagnet would be a
time-losing variant system but in recent
years people have discovered more
interesting ways to preserve time versus
symmetry in a condensed matter system
for example this topological insulator
where you have
electrons going
this way and that way
but also electrons carry spins so the
springs can point up and point down so
momentum and spin they are both reversed
on the timing versus symmetry but
because for example in this branch in
this blue branch the the electrons are
coming towards us with spins pointing up
and the time was a partner will be
electrons going away from us with
springs pointing down so the electrons
coming time was a partners and therefore
the whole system is a time also
environment
and this is actually a very nontrivial
way for a kinase matter system to become
muscle invariant it has created a lot of
and it's it's called topological and has
created a lot of excitement in the
community
so uh so so i've talked about what is
gauging uh what is time reversal so what
does it mean to put these two things
together for example um
can we do something similar to putting a
flux through a conductor ring for
example if we have a time was invariant
one dimensional system
can we make a ring out of it and put the
time also flux through it or we can
imagine that if we have a two
dimensional system like a topological
insulator
that i show on the previous slide which
has which is also time also invariant
and what does it mean to put a time also
flux through the little hole in the
middle of the two-dimensional sample
so usually people don't talk about
gauging timing work so what has been
talked about more
frequently in the literature is gauging
the charge conservation symmetry assess
thing talking about by calculating to
the uh electric magnetic field so
by the way charge conservation uh we
also call it the u1
symmetry because the symmetry is
the action of the symmetry is to take
at a phase factor of e to the i theta
and e and e is the total number of
electrons in the system so this whole
group of operations form a u1 group so
that's why we call this charge
conservation or u1 symmetry so if this
total number of charges conserved then
the system
uh
is invariant under the symmetry
operation only can change by a total
phase factor
so for you for charge conservation
symmetry uh you couple it uh electric
magnetic field oh sorry
sorry
um this has been done in everyday life
and also people talk about gauging more
non-trivial kind of groups like su 2 or
iso 3 these are being studied very uh
popularly in a high energy standard
model
but what does it mean to gauge time
reversal
and as i'll show you that these
that i can
this this concept actually makes sense
in terms of tensor product states
but
but first i need to tell you why why i
want to do this so you may have a good
reason to couple a conductor to
electromagnetic field or you can say i
have a good reason to study ico2 iso3
gauge theory for high energy
and theories but why do i want to gauge
timeless symmetry
so for me there's
a very simple reason because gauging
turns out to be a very useful probe of
the physical properties of the kinase
matter system i have for example if i
have a conductor
the first thing we're learning middle
school even younger is that we couple it
to a charge or a magnetic field and
measure the conductance or the magnetic
susceptibility
of the system that tells me a lot about
the property of the inner working of the
system
but moreover um
gauging symmetry
has turned out to be
a very useful probe for topological
order and that's the thing i'm going to
focus on because i'll be setting a gap
system so unlike what charlemagne has
been talking about the system i'm going
to be focusing on have an energy gap but
they have some kind of topological order
meaning that they have
non-trivial properties that is not like
a simple product state they have been
they have to be described by a very a
very entangled quantum growing state
so
gauging turns out to be a very uh useful
probe of topological order and i'll give
you some examples of that for example
the first known system
with topological order apart from
superconductor
is this quantum hall system where it's a
two dimensional electron gas electrons
move in a two-dimensional system
and was realized
i forgot to put reference here but it
was found in 1980s but
that
if we add a voltage potential a voltage
drop across the x direction and measure
the current flow in y direction you can
see these exactly quantized plateaus
of the conductance in the system so this
is called the the hog conductance um the
quantum hall effect
in a two-dimensional electron gas
and um so
and this uh conductor is hot conductance
is usually denoted by uh sigma xy
um so in this quantum hall system
it turns out that spreading flux can be
a very effective way of measuring this
hot conductance instead of just
putting a voltage drop and measuring a
current in the other direction what we
can do is to spread the magnetic flux
through the system so this is a this is
a
insulator
and the the charge is conserved in the
system so it has a u1 charge
conservation symmetry and we can spread
the magnetic flux of magnitude say phi
and what we will find is that
during this process of threading a flux
we have accumulated some charge around
this flux and this charge is exactly
sigma x y times this flux phi
so by threading a flux we can measure
this important topological quantity
in the quantum heart system which tells
us
the basic feature of this topological
system
okay so we can also imagine that we can
break down this u1 symmetry to something
smaller for example in a superconductor
in a superconductor the
number of total number of charges is no
longer conserved so
the superconductor doesn't have a u1
symmetry but instead it has a z2
symmetry because it's a firm formionic
system and the parity of the fermions
still have to be conserved so it either
has uh even number of fermions or it
have no odd number of fermions so the u1
symmetry is broken down to a z2 symmetry
and because of this breaking down of
this continuous group to this discrete
group
we know that superconductor has the
so-called meissner effect that we cannot
thread just any
value of magnetic flux through the
system because it will be expelled but
instead we can create a fire finite
energy
magnetic flux through the system which
is quantized
to this value of h over 2e
so so if you have a two-dimensional
superconductor we can put the magnetic
flux of h over 2e
through the system and what we will find
is that if the system is topological
there are certain non-trivial things
going on for example if the
system is a p wave superconductor
meaning that the pairing is uh symmetric
then um
what happens when we thread such a flux
through the system is that at this point
of flux threading you will find a zero
machine zero mode
so um so this is
discovered by a red and green in 2000 in
2000 and has been a very effective way
of detect uh creating a mahogany mode
so more recently there has been more
work because there have been a lot of
more topological phases found and the
gauging symmetry has becoming a very
popular way to
identify
or to distinguish these phases for
example in um
the first paper was a well levine and
group proposing that in two-dimensional
bosonic z2 sp symmetry protective
topological phases that gauging the z2
symmetry
can provide a way to distinguish trivial
and non-trivial topological phases and
similarly there are many other
proposals about gauging symmetry in 2d
also we can consider gauging symmetry in
3d for example
in this um
a work by xiaohung on topological
insulator we can couple fermionic
topological insulator to electric
magnetic field because it's an insulator
conserved charge and what we find is
that um this uh
this
setup term in the
low energy description of fermionic
topological insulators and furthermore
it has been proposed that something
similar but different happens in the
bosonic topological insulator which is
proposed by maliki kane and fisher
with something called the statistical
return effect so i'm not going to
go into details about this but just to
point out that gauging symmetry
has been a very effective way
at least theoretically to identify
phases with topological order and to
distinguish them and this also applies
to
system
topological order called the symmetry
enriched topological order meaning that
the system has some
quasi-particle
uh excitations and on top of that we
have extra symmetry enrichment
of these uh of this of this topological
order
so um
so naturally uh
one might consider whether all this
applies to system with timeless or
symmetry because
when we studied all these similar
signature protective topological orders
symmetry in rich topological order
time reversal is naturally included in
our study and we have found a lot of
systems which are non-trivial protected
or enriched by top load but by time we
also symmetry for example in this in one
dimension
was realized that uh
uh if you have a spin one chain of if
you have a chain of spin one and they
interact in this way
then the ground state has some has the
one-dimensional symmetry protective
topological order protected by time
warsaw basically the one-dimensional
chain
on the edge of the one-dimensional chain
there's a spring one half and the spring
one have transformed on the time
reversal in a very different way
from integer springs basically a spin
one half transforms as t squared equal
to minus one instead of t squared equal
to plus one for integer spins
so this aklt chain even though it's made
of spin ones
the effective edge degree of freedom
transform as a fractional of that
underlying degree of freedom so it's uh
something it has the symmetry protected
topological order and is protected by
time reversal symmetry
and also in uh
higher than 1d we have found a lot of
more examples
beyond this aklt state for example this
topological insulator example i was
talking about
so can we for all these semi-time
reversal symmetry protected and time
will also enrich topological order
can we potentially
define something called gauging time
reversal
and
use them to identify or distinguish
topological orders like this well this
may not be a very a physical way because
i don't know what is time wars or gauge
fielding in the lab but at least i can
imagine numerically we may be able to
do something
so now comes the third question so
exactly
what do i need to do how can i gauge
time over so symmetry
well
um
suppose that we have a system which is
well
suppose that the system is gap suppose
we have a gap system which is time
muscle invariant what exactly do we have
to do to couple the system to attach say
your timer so flux
well in order to answer this question we
need to go back and think more carefully
about what exactly we did to couple say
a conductor
to a magnetic flux and if we can
say clearly what we did in that case
maybe it can help us think what we need
to do here
so
imagine that we have a one-dimensional
ring where electron can uh hop on the
ring
and there's a famous effect proposed by
a haranov and ball that if you have
electron hopping on the ring and if you
put a magnetic flux through it
then what happens is that the wave
function
have a twisted boundary condition
basically if the flux is zero
the wave function should be periodic
meaning that uh the wave function at l
should be
the same as the wave function at zero so
so the l is the total length of the ring
but however if we have a non-zero flux
through the ring
then
the wave function at l would be
different from the wave function at
point zero by phase factor of e to the i
e phi over h bar here e this e is the
electric charge
so putting a flux through a conductor
ring
amongst to twisting the boundary
condition of a quantum mechanical system
so this is uh
so that that was a single particle
formulation of this agaron of bomb
effect but uh so here we are considering
many body systems so we need a we need a
second quantization we better put it
into a mini body formulation
so
let's describe electrons hopping on a
ring with a lattice model where the well
just like charlene will sheldon wrote
down electron helping in this one
dimensional system so c1 diagram c2 c2
diagram etc so if there's no flux this
is the hamiltonian of my system
uh with some chemical potential which i
forgot to add
and it's easy to see that this
hamiltonian
is invariant under global charge
conservation symmetry on the global u1
symmetry so this symmetry global
symmetry is e to the i theta
and total n total is the total number of
charge in the system
and theta is arbitrary phase factor from
0 to 2 pi
and obviously this
total hamiltonian is invariant under
this global symmetry
basically because this global symmetry
you can break it up into
actions on different lattice sites so
the total
number of electrons in the system is a
summation over
number of electrons at different lattice
sites so each lattice on each lattice
site
the symmetry operation breaks up into e
to the i theta
and k where n k is the number of
electrons on that site so the total
so the global symmetry breaks up into
local pieces
and and the c dagger and c operator
transforms under these uh local
operations basically a c dagger
transforms under this local operation by
gaining a phase factor of e to the i
theta and the c operator transforms by
losing a phase factor of e to the i
theta and by putting them together we
see that the whole hamiltonian is a
charge conservation charge conserved
okay why i go into so much detail about
this obvious symmetry conservation
because
once i put a flux through the ring
then what happens is that i change the
hamiltonian by just one term on the
boundary so i take i pick up this term
this cn
c1 term this is on the boundary and i
add a phase factor in front of it e to
the i phi so this phi is just the flux i
put through the ring
and you can see that this change in the
hamiltonian can be generated
by
applying a local symmetry transformation
on this boundary term so this so this is
no longer the global symmetry
transformation if i apply the global
symmetry transformation on this boundary
term this term would still be invariant
so nothing would happen but however i
only twist the
hamiltonian on one side of the boundary
so i only apply symmetry on side n
but not on side one
and by doing that uh this um
and i apply the symmetry operation
corresponding to the flux that i thread
through the through the ring by doing
that this boundary term will gain a
phase factor of e to the i5 and this is
exactly
what is done in order to
couple this one-dimensional ring
to a magnetic flux
so we can see that in order to couple a
system with u1 charge conservation
symmetry to a u1 flux what we need is we
need two steps first of all we need a
local action of symmetry
remember that we broke down this global
action of u1 into local action of phase
factors for each site
and the second step is to take the
boundary
take the boundary and twist the boundary
by applying the symmetry only on one
side of the boundary but not on the
other side
does this operation also change the c n
minus one dagger c n term
c one
sorry c one minus well but that's
exactly what you're seeing now well i
don't know exactly how you're defining
this operation i'm sorry let me see your
question applying an operation on site n
does that be is that all you're doing
yes
that also makes other terms
yeah exactly so i'm not saying that i'm
applying this operator to the whole
hamiltonian i'm just taking the boundary
term applying the hamiltonian to the
boundary term just twisting the boundary
term
yeah all the other terms remain variant
so it's not a unitary transformation
it's not a unitary on the hamiltonian if
i yeah
so
so the point is that away from the
boundary it seems nothing has happened
but just at the boundary looks like i
have applied the symmetry to half of the
system
and that's a very important point that i
will come back to uh later
all right so um so this is what we did
for uh u1
charge conservation symmetry so the
question becomes can we do something
similar for time reversal
so obviously we need to we need to
satisfy the two conditions first of all
we need a local action of time also
symmetry can we decompose time inverse
so also into something like t1 cross t2
cross t tn
like that and second of all we need if
we find this local action of symmetry we
need to say how do we need to how do we
add a symmetry twist corresponding to
time movers or symmetry operation
through say a one dimensional ring or a
two dimensional system
and thirdly if
after adding this symmetry twist how can
we probe
the time versus symmetry related
topological order so that's the three
step i'm going to talk about
okay
so
it turns out there's a reason that uh
why time investor symmetry is not gauged
so often like u1 or su2 or z2 symmetry
is because it's very different from all
the other symmetries it's anti-unitary
so this is uh wigner first proposed that
time reversal symmetry has this weird
property that
if it acts on i which is a number
it changes into minus i so this is
something fundamental on this um
quantum mechanical nature uh this this
complex nature of quantum mechanics and
and it doesn't happen for all the other
symmetries that i've been talking about
like u1 z2 as u2 they're all unitary
symmetries
but time reversal is anti-unitary and
that's that that makes all the
difference
so the
global symmetry action of time reversal
on a canon's matter system
has this complex conjugation part so
this k refers to complex conjugation
apart from that it can also have unitary
transformations that's fine but it's a
composition of two parts unity
transformation and complex conjugation
for example on spin one half
on time this unitary transformation is i
sigma y and what it does is to map zero
to one one to minus zero that's all fine
because it means that i flipped the spin
from up to down down to up
but
once you
have a superposition of zero in one
state for example alpha zero plus beta1
and apply time also symmetry what
happens is that you need to take complex
conjugation of the coefficient also not
just to
map the basis state
so this is a fundamental difference
between time muscle symmetry and unitary
symmetries
so this um
this unitary transformation of i say i
sigma y is very similar to what we saw
in for unitary symmetries and they are
and they their actions are decomposed
onto each lattice side onto each spin
one half but however this complex
conjugation looks like a very big
operation you take a wave function or
you take the hamiltonian and you apply
the complex conjugation
all together how can we define a local
action of complex conjugation
so there's a very simple case where you
you say oh i
there's a very naive way to apply
complex conjugation because for example
let's consider a product state this
simplest many body wave function that
you can have
um
of this form where it's a product of
each spring one half
and you can just say that complex
conjugation on spin one is just taking
complex conjugation on this product wave
function of spin 1 i'm just taking
complex conjugation on this alpha and
beta but not all the other rf and betas
okay so for product say the problem is
solved but what about entangled state
because for entangled state we have this
big civil position we have all the basic
state i1 through in and the coefficient
is a big number how can we say what does
it mean to just partial
to complex conjugated alongside one but
not on sine n
well you may have guessed the answer
because i advertise it it's uh
using the tensor product representation
it turns out that the
product representation gives us a way
to break up this big coefficient in your
antibody wave function into local pieces
so this is the
this is the matrix product state and
this is a two-dimensional
tensor product state in a matrix product
state this big coefficient
is written as
the trace
over a bunch of matrices
so this is usually what i draw and as a
matrix product state where these are
vertical
lines are the physical indices and the
horizontal lines are in the indices for
the matrices which are contracted
altogether
so um
so these uh so in two dimension we don't
have a matrix products anymore we have
tensor product space where the the
indices can go horizontal and vertical
and there are there are physical
uh indices pointing out of the plane
and because of this breaking up of this
big coefficient of wave function into
local pieces we can now have a
meaningful way to define what is a local
action of complex conjugation basically
we take this
complex conjugation of matrices on site
one or the tensor on side one and that
give that
that uh that can be defined just as
local action of complex conjugation now
this may sound very uh
simple and
natural to do for people working on
matrix products intensive product states
um but
and i'll show that this actually uh is
very useful as a probe for topological
order so there is a problem with this
because
so there could be many different
representations so the representation is
not written exactly yes yes exactly so
unlike product states these are matrices
or tensors they're not unique
so this complex conjugation may involve
some uh
uh
so they may depend on the choice of
gauge
exactly so the point uh we are trying to
so in the examples that we are trying to
show is that the way
we use this
local definition of time reversal and
the threading flux procedure to identify
topological order will be independent of
this gauge choice so that's a basic
requirement of what would we do
so okay this gives a local definition of
complex conjugation and
very naturally the local definition of
time was so follows by just
applying whatever unitary that has to be
done to say the first spin whether you
need to flip the spin or do whatever
that's totally fine
okay so we solve the first problem we
have a local definition of symmetry on
tensor product states and secondly
we need to uh talk about how to add a
symmetry twist corresponding to
threading a time also flux
through a one-dimensional ring
so this is related to some very nice
properties of matrix product states and
tensor product states under symmetry
transformation
so
it was realized
in this 2008 paper
by people sitting in the audience that
um
matrix product states have a transform
on the symmetry in a very special way so
basically if us if we have a matrix
product states which is
symmetric under this symmetry
transformation where the symmetry is
applied as u on each side
then the measure then the matrix is
representing the state doesn't have to
be invariant under this symmetry instead
it only has to be invariant up to some k
transformation m
and m inverse on each side
and this is because
once we put all these matrices together
and into a many body wave function we
can see that
these ma these gauge transformations
they cancel with each other so the m
from the first side cancel with the oh
sorry the m inverse from the first side
cancel with the m from the second side
and so on and so forth and we take the
periodic boundary condition everything's
gone
so even though the representing tensors
they are not
they they change under this symmetry
action the wave function they represent
is still invariant
and this is actually the reverse
direction is also proven that
whenever we have a gapped
one-dimensional mps that has this
symmetry then the tens then the matrix
products say representation the matrix
is representing the state will transform
under symmetry like this by a m and m
inverse gage transformation
so
so okay so
because of this we can see what happens
when we add symmetry locally
in on a matrix product states
for example if we acted
on two sides
now we can see that in the middle of the
system
these gauge transformations in the
middle of the segment where we apply the
local symmetry and the gauge
transformation cancels and only
something on the boundary changes
so if we apply this uh the symmetry on a
segment you can see a domain word here
and the domain were here but inside and
outside everything looks nothing
happened
okay
so
so if we ever want to do something like
a symmetry twist
then that's like a single domain rule
along a ring of the system now we can
imagine that what happens is to insert
just one of the operators
into the one-dimensional chain so if we
have m here and inverse there that would
correspond to two domain words but that
would be a segment if we want to just do
a twist we would just put one of the
operators here another not another one
which which correspond to the other end
of the symmetry operator
so so this this sounds like a
like a wave function way
to define what what it means to thread a
flux but previously i talked about how
to
twist how to do the twist on the
hamiltonian so are these two consistent
and actually
they are consistent if the ground state
is gapped
so
suppose that we have a one-dimensional
hamiltonian like this and what i
proposed to twist the hamiltonian
if i spread the flux corresponding to
the symmetry u
is that i take the boundary term h and 1
only the boundary term
and
apply the symmetry
u n and u n inverse sorry this is u n
inverse not u n minus 1.
um
so i apply the symmetry on one side of
the boundary
so you can see that
um what hap what what happens to the
hamiltonian is that away from the
boundary
nothing changes all the term remains the
same
but at the boundary it looks like i have
applied the same transformation on one
side so it doesn't matter if i write a u
u n or u n
uh tensor product with u n minus one
tensor product with u n minus two i can
take a even larger or similar
transformation that will give me the
same effect but the point is that at the
symmetry i had a boundary sorry at the
boundary it looks like i've done
symmetry transformation only on one side
so this is what happens
to the hamiltonian
and you can see that
by inserting this operator
into this one-dimensional mps it exactly
corresponds to this gauge transformation
on the hamiltonian because away from the
boundary
nothing happens
but at the boundary it looks like i have
applied symmetry on say this half line
of the chain but not yeah and then you
will never be able to find the other
uh domain word so
so
sorry what is the piston
uh no i don't know that
so that's a good question
well i guess you could probably have it
from the mps by looking at the clean
boxes
or something exactly so for time
reversal i need to make this connection
because i define everything on top in
terms of this wave function but it would
be nice to have a formulation in terms
of hamiltonian you can say that why
don't you just
go back and see what happens to the
hamiltonian you can have a corresponding
definition i don't find a very nice
definition but it would be good if if
someone comes up with idea so this
picture don't work with time russell
this is how i define uh what is okay
what is threading a flux for time muscle
for the wave function for the
hamiltonian i don't have a verb
i don't know what it means
it would be nice if i say take a
hamiltonian term what it means to
separate the coefficient into left and
right part you might say it's a matrix
product operator and i don't know it
doesn't seem to be very um
direct yeah anyway
so
um so this this this correspondence
happens for unitary symmetry that's a
very good point um but um
but of course um
this this is generically true this
correspondence between hamiltonian and
ground state is generically true for gap
ground state if you have if you don't
have a gap ground state this is not true
for example in the one-dimensional
conductor that shall talk about what i
talked about previously it's not true
that the wave function will have a phase
accumulation around the ring but
for gap ground states
if you only twist the hamiltonian along
the boundary and the wave function only
changes at the boundary and this is uh
this is actually
proposed as a generic property for gap
hamiltonians in the paper by
ravi hastings mathematics
when they when they try to prove the
stability of topological order
on that okay i'll state the statements
the statement is that for
there's certain class of
uh
hamiltonian gap hamiltonian such that
um the ground state it reduces the
matrix in a ground state is determined
by
local hamiltonian terms in that region
but not affected by something far apart
so that's the t what they call the
topological quantum order condition two
in a paper
and um
so here what it means is that if the
hamiltonian term doesn't change i should
expect the
ground state reduces the matrix also
doesn't change
but if the hamiltonian changes like that
i should expect the ground state to
change like that so there's a
correspondence between the change in
hamiltonian changing in its gap ground
state
make sense but but i believe that it's
an assumption that the gap stays
uh is what sorry that the gap stays open
is an assumption the gaps is open yeah
it's not just a condition on before you
prefer it's not just a condition
unless the perturbations are small
but if it's um if it's one operation
then anything can happen
are you asking whether it's only for
fixed point hamiltonian or
what why does um perturbation
so
the results of probably hastings
refer to sufficiently small
perturbations
and this is
you can also prove if the gap stays open
then
the perturbations only have local
effects
yeah so what i'm talking about is it has
nothing to do with the stability of gap
i'm just talking about some condition
they put on the gap hamiltonian before
they prove the stability of the gap
uh this is just some property between
these telling because the capital
existed before you applied view but you
applied you you changed hamiltonian so
the gap can change or even close that's
what he's saying oh okay okay
uh that's a good point but i don't think
i have another local person
i know there's two one maybe kept
another might be given
okay that's a good point yeah absolutely
yeah that's a good point yeah thank you
um
i don't think it happens here
just changing one term close the gap
small for um l
because this view is a citizen so you
can spread this piece in very high
yeah if that's a u1 twist and it does a
z2 twist
right uh is there an example that you
add a twist and you close the gap
um
i
i don't know thank you
she can certainly change
yeah and that's true
that means that the gap that something
that was unique those gaps i mean just
it can certainly kind of become two for
each other
that's a unitary transformation
but these are the one that meanwhile
if this is a
challenge correlated you would say okay
one two
two uh two dominoes
yeah i'll just do this
all right
um okay so
so this this shows the correspondence of
definition
of gauging on the hamiltonian level and
the ground state level for unitary
symmetries but i'll just take this
definition
for ground state for wave functions for
time inverse of symmetry because there's
no definition for hamiltonian for time
versus symmetries
okay
so
it was pointed out in uh
and it's gonna ask so
changing the second component of the
spin for one of the interaction terms by
a minus sign would not
serve your purpose
consider the
yeah i don't know whether that's a
generic way to do it
it um on what you want to do right what
you want to see from this operation
so
so my um
my impression is that for hamiltonian i
didn't find a very good way to formulate
this
um okay so
so it was pointed out in the paper by
frank pullman and other people
in 2010 that um similar properties holds
for matrix product states on the time
versus symmetry so basically by taking
complex conjugation and applying unity
the unity operation necessary
the mps would change also by a gauge
transformation like that if the mps
represented is time was so symmetric
also there are many cases
i'll talk about examples
where in two dimension
we can imagine that applying time muscle
symmetry locally basically taking
complex conjugation applying unitary
would induce gauge transformations in uh
in all four directions and then i'm
inversing this direction and n inverse
in that direction so that they cancel
out
whenever
together i can say t what is that sigma
stupid
put
y or something yes
yes
i think i have a slice later for that i
may have sliced later on look at the
next next slide
um so
so to putting a symmetry twist
through one dimensional ring would be uh
insert the m here and to put a symmetry
twist through two dimensional systems
imagine that we have periodic boundary
conditions and we want to put a flux
along one of the non-trivial loop
then
what we need to do is to insert these
operators along a non-trivial loop
in the torus
okay so we have finished the second step
and uh
so the third one would be
to use this procedure to identify
topological order related to time versus
symmetry and
what we found is that this can come out
of the
composition rules of
time reversal twist but the composition
rules have a
adjective which is projective meaning
that
while we would expect that composing two
time rules or fluxes should give you
nothing because
you do time muscle once you do time
versus twice you get back but however
composing two time muscle fluxes
sometimes don't give us
the exact state but only the state up to
a phase factor
so that's how topological order may be
identified
and this is actually uh
this has actually been done for matrix
product states for years and uh people
know this and has been used a lot for uh
classifying say measure a symmetrical
protagonic topological order in 1d but
but here i'm just reinterpreting it
reinterpreting the 1d procedure as
gauging time muscle symmetry and then
i'll be generalizing
this what we do what we did for 1d to
higher dimensions
so in one day it's known that um
this transformation holds for the matrix
product representation with on the time
muscle symmetry and if we thread the
flux we have m
and then if we spread the nanoflux
uh we can insert another m but because
this is time versus symmetry so somehow
we need to take the complex conjugation
of the first m and now we can talk about
the composition of the two
so
usually we would imagine that the two
flux should combine into nothing but
however it's proven that this
m star m
can be either plus one or minus one and
plus one correspond sorry plus one
corresponds to a trivial phase and minus
one corresponds to this non-trivial aklt
state where the matrices are given by
sigma x sigma y sigma z and the
time muscle symmetry is complex
conjugation together with a spin flip
and this m
is i sigma y which has this property of
m star m equals minus one
so that indicates
a complex conjugation sorry
yeah but sigma y is also uh but it's
also like conventional conjugation y
yes yes
so but you have sigma y squared is one
but i squared minus 1.6
yeah but it's but this
minus one is uh it doesn't depend on the
face of them
yeah
right is
it's just this matrix is i times sigma y
it's a 2 by 2 matrix
what do you mean sorry anti-linear
yeah you can you can think of um
actually as a anti-linear operator
because that's why
that's why we took complex conjugation
of the first m when we composed them so
you can imagine they come they come with
k
yeah yeah you can put a k in here so
that you don't have to put this star
here
ordinary matrices the equation is true
even though m star equals n
the equation is nonetheless correct yeah
and the point is that this as a number
pointed out this the total phase factor
of this m is not meaningful because we
also always have m and m inverse
appearing pairs so you can change the
phase factor of m by whatever
you like and this you can just put sigma
y
but if you put sigma y here you can you
can still see that sigma y star sigma y
is still minus one because sigma y is
complex
okay okay so this is the one-dimensional
case and it's been well known in uh
in the matrix product state
uh in the study of matrix product states
and we are trying to generalize all
these understanding to higher dimensions
and see
how it can allow us to
uh identify and distinguish symmetry
protected hot blood color or other
topological order into one high
dimension so we did a very simple
example here which is a
spd order with z2
and time versus symmetry so um
so in 2d if we only have time muscle
symmetry there's there are no
um spd phases so everything is trivial
so what we need to do is to put time
muscle together with some other symmetry
so here we choose this z2 symmetry
and and there's a non-trivial phase here
and what happens is that
if we create a z2 symmetry flux
in the system it would transform
as a spin one half it would transform as
t squared equal to minus one so you can
imagine that what we propose to do is to
thread time also fluxes through the
pseudo-non-trivial ring
along one direction for example we can
have one flux like that
and another one
and uh
we can allow them we can uh we can see
how they compose and try to see from
that process if there's a projected
phase factor coming out but a z2
symmetry flux transformer t squared with
a minus sign i mean z2 just so this is
unitary signature right uh yes sorry
it's a z2
end of the flux defect
line yeah
but we're not ending things here
um okay so um
oops
so if we are if we just
allow them to combine like that we don't
see anything happening this is basically
consistent with the fact that if we only
consider time versus symmetry the state
is totally trivial that nothing happens
if it's just timeless or symmetry and
somehow we need to put in the fact that
it's a it's a the the the interaction
between z2 and time was so that's
non-trivial so what would you say that's
an m times star will be equal to one in
this particular example uh not
necessarily one but um
but the total action on the states will
be trivial
but could be minus one you could have
phase difference oh well if it's minus
one then two
it's not minus one anyway so it the
action on the indices may be non-trivial
but because here we don't have injective
tensors
so the the at the end of the day the
ground the wave function is still the
invariant
not in the phase change
no no phase change
so what we need to do is to um
put a z2 flux in this direction and
similarly z2 flux what you need to
insert here comes from the local z2
symmetry action on each lattice side
so we insert the z2 flux in this
direction and
and insert two time muscle fluxes in
that direction
and then something happens because now
if we
allow these two
time muscle fluxes to analyze each other
we see a minus one fixed factor so this
you can imagine that actually what we
we're doing is to
imagine taking the taurus and cutting it
open and then we're inserting a z2 flux
in this direction so we create two flux
endpoints at the end and that measures
the t square equal to minus one at the
end um
i want to see the composition rule i
want to see two how to
time also flux composed to trivial so
this
yeah yeah yeah basically because it's a
it's a periodic boundary condition
so
when you uh annihilate them so actually
something has to go through this thing
and that's where the minus one comes up
so this is very similar if we compare to
a very simple case a 2d z2 spd order so
we know that with just z2 symmetry
there's a non-trivial spd order in 2d
and what happens is that the z2 flux
if it ever if the flux line ever ends up
anywhere it it's something like the
little flux carries half the two charge
so if you measure the d2 symmetry twice
you should get a minus one and this is
exactly what we see if we do something
like this we insert a z2 flux in this
direction and we insert two z2 flux in
the horizontal direction and we
annihilate them and we see a minus one
so that means the z2 flux carry half z2
charge
um so the the last example that we did
is to gauge the z2 symmetry so
so previously we talked about symmetry
protected topological phases which are
short-ranging tango but here we can
gauge the z2 symmetry and have a z2
gauge theory with time versus symmetry
and we can um
do the same process and see what happens
so here instead of
symmetry fluxes we can insert gauge
fluxes and this will be a gauge twist
line
and
but for time versus symmetry is still a
symmetry and we insert these operators
corresponding to the symmetry
transformations and still we get a minus
one
okay so to summarize
i'm almost
my time but uh
what we did is to um
define a local action of time versus
symmetry in terms of tensor network
states
and propose how to add a symmetry twist
into the state by inserting operators
into the inner indices
of the representation and finally use
the projective composition rules of this
symmetry twist um to probe the
topological order
so um so there are many uh so this is a
this is a very
first step maybe
in gauging time water symmetry if the
concept
i imagine the concept should
be more general for
first of all we want to
um
we want this process
to be a generic tool
for
detecting time reversal related
topological order for example uh what we
haven't been able to do is to see how
this works out
in three-dimensional symmetry protective
topological phases it turns out there's
something
in 3d with time versus symmetry there's
something very non-trivial going on and
uh
and so that's the next step and uh
furthermore for example with these
topological insulators and silver
conductors whether it makes sense to
whether we can do similar things of
inserting a time was so flux and um
and see something instead of inserting a
u1 flux
and also i want to see i hope that this
process of gauging time will also can be
defined in more general context like
already mentioned in the talk for
example
in terms of hamiltonian
so
so this uh with the matrix product
states we we our tensor products that we
can define it in terms of wave function
but if i want to define it in terms of
hamiltonian i need a good
criteria to say
what is a good way to do that what is a
meaningful way would independent of all
the gauge independent of all the things
that i don't care about but still give
me uh invariant and meaningful answers
so that's something we're looking for
and also for gapley system because
for gabler system
uh whether this inserting internet
operators
operators onto inner illnesses still
works i'm not sure
um
well basically if we know how to do do
it for hamiltonian we know how to do it
with to gap the system because
hamiltonian doesn't care about whether
it's gap or gapless but i don't know
whether that's a fundamental difference
why i can only do it for wave function
and thirdly if this works in a
space-time formulation that would be
more interesting because uh because if i
have a time direction i'm actually
reversing the time direction and taking
a point t and the minus t and
put them together
and finally
if there is a dynamical theory for time
was a gauge field so for now all we are
doing is to use the non-dynamical
configuration
for something we made we might call time
also gauge field just like a fixed flux
configuration but for u1 gauge theory we
know there's a dynamical gauge theory of
many other unitary
symmetries
unitary groups we can define a dynamical
gauge theory so whether this exists for
for the time versus okay field that i
don't know
okay thank you
you want to see more about the
three-dimensional
okay so
i imagine you can
you can insert the plots in different
directions that nothing happens i mean
so in three dimension um
so there is one within cosmology there
is one out of cosmology i would imagine
that
things would be very different for the
one out of cosmology because
so the within cosmology one has is very
similar to what what happens in one and
two basically you apply symmetry
operation
uh you see something happening on the
edge but something happening on the
edges
is very simple operation like in 2d it's
a line of operators
just like that but for the beyond the
homology thing because there's the
surface state we know something about
the surface state the surface state
if i break time versus symmetry i know
on one side it's the trivial state on
the other side it's the ea state so it's
it's like saying that time also symmetry
on the boundary will be mapping between
a trivial state and ea state which has
different chorality even
and
and that requires a very big quantum
circuit to do that you cannot do that
with a one layer of unitary symmetry or
even finite layers of them so the
picture will be very different if if i
can write down a tensor network
representation of the beyond tophomology
uh
uh spt
i don't even i don't even know how it
would look like i act time warsaw
symmetry and so so so there is uh yeah
so it's this technical homology there's
an issue about whether there is a
transcendental representation uh i think
there is but um it's this picture that
breaks down it's not just simple
operators like that where you put them
together and they cancel each other it's
still on the boundaries on the boundary
it grows it's something very complicated
we can
we have exactly several models but it's
um
i don't know
the short answer is i don't know
yeah
yes
so so did you try to lift this to the
physical level and what kind of operator
do you get then because or is it
something very ugly that you get so you
can
put that verse from playing on the
physical level yes that's a
transformation that you have to do on
your hamiltonian but
yes but but uh what is that
you can you can for particular uh cases
if you have a fixed tensor
representation you can extract the
unitaries like that like foreign
yeah it would be some sigma y or
something but the point is that you
change the gauge
you change the gauging of the mps and
the unitary changes
and
i
i haven't made sense of uh the
corresponding operator on the
hamiltonian yet
well but it doesn't operate you can
acquire something on the virtual level
that is equivalent to acting on the phys
on a few sides of the physical level
that is related to correlation yes yes
and and that operator is not as simple
as
no no no operator is a simple operator
for example just imagine a bunch of
singlets and you're twisting a boundary
condition so you're just acting on one
of the spin one half and
the operator is a well-defined operator
for each nps representation you choose
but you change the gauge the
corresponding operator changes and
that's a class of operator and i haven't
made sense of that class of operator yet
what's the
criteria for setting that class of
operators saying that that's the action
that i should do to my hamiltonian to
gauge timeless image
so that's the question
makes sense
it's it yeah it is it is it's mapping
between wave functions
all right let's thank you again